you recently it's all going your way you
recently launched a champagne is this
I'm pronouncement we have some right now
is this prick that should mean the ROI
is that that's right I mean to Roy and
and you brought and this is your
champagne how did you pick your
champagne I got it straight from Rennes
France
it's right there right there huh
you just killed our lighting director
was impressive that was really
impressive just trying to make sure no
you sued okay so this is this is your
this is this is Curtis fitty cent
Jackson's champagne this is the only
champagne you drink now right right this
is the king's bath
yeah this is some pretty sweet stuff
share it we're not allowed to serve you
alcohol during the show this is not some
crappy nightclub or is it power airs
Sundays at 8:00 on Starz I'm gonna try
this mm-hmm yeah it's very good that
it's very good
that's delicious that's fantastic my 86
years yeah age for what it's been it's
been in those bottles for six years oh
six years I think you said 86 that's
like that's disgusting I have a disease
now that hasn't been around for a
hundred and ten years conan died today
of cholera I want to mention power and
also this is a less mean to Roy I
think this stuff is really good it's
very nice and maybe someone in the
audience is gonna get some in the
commercial break but maybe not
Tara thank you
you